[Musica]
chi conosce la festa di sant'efisio ma
anche chi la vive per la prima volta
anche come semplice spettatore
devo dire che si rende subito conto che
non si tratta di una semplice
manifestazione religiosa una delle tante
centinaia che si svolgono in tutto il
territorio regionale ma immediatamente
si rende conto che la festa di
sant'efisio porta dietro di sé e con sé
molti elementi di grande interesse mette
insieme tante anime quella devozionale
quella della tradizione quella inclusiva
degli aspetti popolari e lascia emergere
questo carattere identitario dei sardi è
una festa secolare particolarmente
sentita partecipata da cagliaritani e
sardi e più in generale ea questa storia
lunga che l'accompagna una storia di 364
anni ininterrotti di fede e di devozione
per le green aggio un percorso che
partendo dalla città da questa sua
piccola chiesetta in uno dei quartieri
storici della nostra città attraversa
cinque comuni percorre fra andata e
ritorno oltre 80 km e dura 4 giorni
coinvolge centinaia migliaia di persone
in modo diretto e indiretto e quindi la
festa di sant'efisio per noi sardi
diventa veramente un elemento di
connessione fra la società arcaica la
civiltà arcaica dell'isola rappresentata
dallo sfarzo di quegli elementi
identitari dell'abbigliamento popolare
della variante linguistica locale di
quelle forme espressive delle traccas
che ci riportano alla civiltà agricola e
contadina
dei cavalli e cavalieri che
rappresentano le tante comunità con i
cavalli addobbati per la festa le
migliaia e migliaia di persone che
snocciolano il rosario intensamente
durante questo pellegrinaggio ecco una
grande manifestazione per un santo che
ha avuto sempre un rapporto estremamente
forte intenso con la città fino al
momento del suo martirio del suo
sacrificio anche un attimo prima così ci
racconta la sua passione della sua
decapitazione del suo martirio ha
pensato a cagliari ha pregato per la
città per i cagliaritani
in fondo i cagliaritani con sant'efisio
hanno un rapporto estremamente
confidenziale noi lo chiamiamo efisio
non lo chiamiamo sant'efisio sappiamo
anche quanto è vicino a questa città in
questa lunga storia io vi ho detto 364
anni perché in realtà tutto è nato nella
metà del seicento e anche allora ahimé
le comunità il pianeta si ammalava
spesso con queste terribili pandemie
allora proprio nel 1652 arriva ad
alghero una antica tartana con dentro un
equipaggio che è riuscito ad eludere la
sorveglianza i controlli allora medici e
la quarantena è così ha portato nella
nostra terra una terribile pestilenza
che ha decimato la nostra popolazione e
di fronte ad un evento come questo
come dire gli uomini e le donne di
questo territorio ma soprattutto la
municipalità cagliaritana ha preso una
solenne impegno di celebrare se fosse e
se la popolazione si fosse salvata da
questa terribile moria di pestilenza
avrebbe reso solenne
il momento celebrativo della festa e
fisia na quindi avrebbe messo a
disposizione tutta la sua forza per
celebrare nel miglior modo possibile
rendere grazie a questo santo sempre
vicino alla città
com'è che allora si rendeva solenne una
processione una manifestazione di
gratitudine nei confronti di un santo
certamente portando con sé la cera per
appunto le fiaccole e l'olio per
illuminare il percorso i suonatori di
tamburo dare i cibi e alle popolazioni
insomma rendere davvero solenne questo
momento in questi 365 anni e ancora oggi
noi cerchiamo di rendere solenne questo
appuntamento come mettendo in vetrina in
scena portando fuori tutto quello che
per noi rappresenta la nostra storia la
nostra il nostro orgoglio più grande
cioè quello che è l'aspetto
dell'abbigliamento identitario che ci
racconta dai primi del settecento fino
al secolo scorso come i sardi si
vestivano come i sardi si riconoscevano
come i sardi si identificavano in
ciascuna comunità attraverso il proprio
abbigliamento popolare
oggi per noi è un motivo di grande
orgoglio poter sfoggiare questi elementi
dell'abbigliamento tradizionale è un
motivo di grande piacere poter indossare
per il santo l'abito di massima gala
indossare i gioielli in filigrana più
preziosi poter pregare ad alta voce e
ciascuna con la sua variante linguistica
locale esprimere il rosario sentirsi
vicino al santo ecco questa dei rosario
è una delle forme collettive che
affascinano tutti i partecipanti i
visitatori che seguono le celebrazioni
della festa
di sant'efisio perché nella preghiera ci
si ritrova con una moltitudine di
varianti perché i rosari cantati
soprattutto nella nostra terra che ha
tante varianti linguistiche noi troviamo
delle cadenze differenti dei ritmi
musicali delle definizioni ciascuna
particolare che racconta un territorio
ecco tutta questa macchina organizzativa
che vede 5000 e passa persone con questi
abiti meravigliosi della nostra cultura
popolare 300 cavalieri oltre 20 traccas
con tre nati da questi giganteschi vuoi
che un tempo erano i migliori compagni
di lavoro del dei contadini del passato
oggi vengono allevati esclusivamente per
poter vivere questa giornata intensa e
per poter portare in scena quella
memoria della tratta che era quell
elemento che come dire contrasti
distingueva nel passato il momento del
lavoro è il momento della festa per la
festa si costruivano questi carri
addobbati con un gusto popolare e con
questi tre nati da questi giganteschi
boy si andava fino al luogo della fede e
della festa e ancora oggi noi vogliamo
in qualche modo rievocare questa
tradizione ecco è tutta questa grande
macchina che si muove in modo armonioso
come in un grande scacchiere all'interno
della città per svilupparsi fattori nei
quattro giorni dal primo al 4 maggio per
attraversare sia la città di cagliari
che i centri che portano a nora il luogo
del martirio di efisio ecco è questa
grande occasione di insieme per alcuni
può sembrare è come dire una processione
quasi spontanea in realtà c'è dietro una
macchina organizzativa davvero
importante io sono un cagliaritano i
cagliaritani con efisio hanno un
rapporto davvero fraterno e è come
sentire la presenza di un familiare ecco
noi fin da piccoli abbiamo vissuto
questa relazione è così stretta e da
cagliaritano avere come dire questo
grande privilegio di condurre una
squadra e avere assumere questo ruolo di
direttore organizzativo per la mia città
per la per il comune della mia città e è
un motivo di grande orgoglio ma insieme
di assoluta preoccupazione
responsabilità la squadra di
collaboratori è formata da oltre 300
persone che ciascuna di esse ha un ruolo
specifico nella organizzazione di questa
grande occasione di fede e quindi in
tanti si adoperano per poter come dire
ogni anno allestire questo momento così
importante quindi pensare alla sicurezza
a pensare all'accoglienza pensare ai
vari gruppi di lavoro i fedeli e che
svolgono la loro processione a piedi
cavalieri miliziani un altro corpo
storico nella processione di sant'efisio
che ancora oggi indossa quelle divise
seicentesche che ci rimandano insomma al
momento in cui i sardi militari
scortavano il santo fino al luogo del
martirio scortavano i fedeli e davano a
ciascuno di loro la tranquillità e la
certezza di poter ogni anno pregare per
il santo e ringraziarlo per aver
liberato la città e la sardegna
da questa terribile pestilenza e il
titolo di queste terre si può fare è
bello pensare che ogni volta che c'è
stato un avvenimento straordinario nella
nostra città
la processione di sant'efisio si è
potuta fare
comunque si è potuta fare io penso alla
fine del 1700 i molti del 1793 dopo
proprio aver difeso la città da questo
attacco francese c'è stata una rivolta
dei cagliaritani ebbene in quella
circostanza per ragioni di sicurezza
pubblica
la festa di sant'efisio è stata soltanto
spostata ma non annullata mai è stata
annullata neanche durante la grande
guerra nel 1916 in quei giorni
drammatici è stata spostata di una
settimana ma si è potuta fare
si è potuta fare anche quell'anno la
festa e la memoria ci riporta ancora al
secolo scorso il 1943 una città ferita a
devastata dai bombardamenti e le sirene
che annunciavano continuamente il dramma
dei bombardamenti alleati e ebbene pian
piano anche lì si è potuta fare
la processione di sant'efisio un
camioncino del latte alcuni fedeli che
sono quasi usciti dalle macerie per
seguire per pregare per ritrovarsi in
questo momento di grande intensità e
quindi anche in quella circostanza si è
potuta fare
ma la ahimè la storia anche se con
scenari diversi ogni volta ci mette a
dura prova
perché anche quest'anno 2020 che stiamo
vivendo ci ha ugualmente come dire messo
a dura prova perché ha condizionato
una delle cose che per noi chiamiamo
insomma
la tradizione popolare quegli aspetti
legati come dire alla nostra cultura
millenaria quella dello stare insieme di
condividere di tenerci mano per la mano
nell'esecuzione del ballo che la più
alta espressione di collettività
d'insieme di festa di voler come deve
significare la propria appartenenza e
bene anche quest'anno con la terribile
pandemia del copit 19 la nostra vita
quella di tutto il pianeta e quindi
anche quella della processione di
sant'efisio è stata fortemente
condizionata ma si è potuta fare
certo non con come dire con quello stile
con quegli elementi a noi così cari e
con quella partecipazione popolare di
un'isola intera di quelle migliaia e
migliaia di persone ma con una intensità
che abbiamo sentito non di presenza
fisica ma di partecipazione ad una
preghiera ad una come dire presenza
anche se soltanto con la parola della
fede con i box con i rosari con la
meditazione
ecco quest'anno abbiamo sentito una
festa di sant'efisio diversa e allora
ecco che non c'è stato il gioco dei
buoni a trainare il cocchio questo
meraviglioso elemento che custodisce la
statua lignea del santo ma ancora una
volta un mezzo come quello nel 43 del
latte questa volta un mezzo della croce
rossa ha ospitato efisio per
accompagnarlo fino a nora dove in quella
circostanza il 3 di maggio è stata
celebrata la
solenne liturgia per ringraziare il
santo di ciò che aveva fatto per noi è
stata una cerimonia che non ha avuto uno
sviluppo di quattro giorni come noi
siamo abituati a vivere è stato tutto
molto
come dire realizzato velocemente perché
quella doveva essere la condizione ma
comunque un voto è stato sciolto anche
nel 2020 per l'edizione numero 364
avremo modo di vedere efisio per le
strade della città
proprio il 15 gennaio il giorno in cui
secondo la tradizione lui è salito al
cielo perché era proprio il 15 di un
freddo gennaio del 303 che proprio nella
spiaggia di nora è stato decapitato ma
anche il lunedì di pasqua perché da
quella assalto francese sventato non
solo dai valorosi miliziani ma anche
dall'intercessione e fisia na ogni
lunedì dell'angelo dal 1793 si va in
cattedrale con il simulacro del santo
per ringraziare efisio per aver liberato
ancora una volta la città e poi
ritroviamo nelle vie di cagliari il
giovedì santo il giro delle sette chiese
che efisio fa con i confratelli e le
consorelle per seguire nei quartieri
della nostra città
i momenti che hanno segnato la passione
e morte di nostro signore gesù cristo
ecco questo è un po l'aspetto che mette
insieme tante anime la fede e la
devozione la partecipazione ma anche di
elementi della festa popolare del ballo
i suoni delle launeddas di quegli
strumenti autoctoni della nostra cultura
millenaria
le esperienze dei cibi la conoscenza e
la sapienza popolare degli elementi
dell'artigianato insomma tante cose che
ci riconducono comunque a questa nostra
tradizione tanto amata da noi sardi ma
credo anche
dalle migliaia e migliaia di visitatori
che ogni anno vengono in sardegna per
condividere questo momento così
importante per tutti noi
il 2020 è stato un anno tragico sotto
questo profilo perché non abbiamo potuto
come dire raccontare la storia del santo
come noi avremmo voluto ma speriamo che
questo prossimo 2021 ci possa
accompagnare recuperare quello che
abbiamo perduto per quest'anno ma che
come dire per altri molti altri secoli
avremo modo di raccontare non si può che
chiudere questo intervento parlando di
efisio in un modo in cui ogni volta il 4
maggio un po prima della mezzanotte il
primo guardiano racconta la città alla
sua eccellenza l'arcivescovo di cagliari
al signor sindaco di cagliari che il
voto è stato sciolto e quindi si
conclude dicendo a cruz andos
[Musica]